president biden throwing unity out the
window and running full speed ahead with
a divisive midterm strategy saying mega
republicans threaten our democracy while
calling out the philosophy as
semi-fascism whatever that means it
signals a more aggressive approach as
biden gets ready to embark on a
nationwide travel blitz apparently it's
going to be a blitz 71 days until
election day the democratic national
committee chair he seems to be on board
president biden said we should not view
each other as adversaries in this
country but as neighbors and we should
treat each other with dignity and
respect how does semi-fascism as a label
for
the republican party fit with that
inaugural address
the one thing that president joe biden
has been has always been consistent and
he has always been somebody who
does what my grandfather used to do
which is speak it plain mr chairman you
embrace the rhetoric semi-fascism to
describe the republican party well it's
not about the embracing is calling what
what what it is what it is biden's new
tone is not sitting well with new
hampshire's usually reserved republican
governor
he's trying to stir up this
anti-republican sentiment right before
the election
it's just it's horribly inappropriate
it's insulting and people should be
insulted and he should apologize and
watch this even the liberal media is
questioning the tactic
there's no back peddling on this it's
clear that there's a more aggressive
strategy it fires up democrats it juices
up the base because they want to see him
be more aggressive on that but it also
does you know it does become problematic
because you know this is a guy who said
he wanted to be a unifier so harold two
weeks ago the president signed the
inflation reduction act too much fanfare
and they were feeling a little momentum
gas prices had started to tick down and
then he decided to
basically bail out several thousand
million people with their student loans
and he topped it off with this comment
about maga republicans being
semi-fascist so that obviously was a
strategy and now everybody on the
democratic side is using this language
do they have some focus group that said
this is going to be a real winner
i don't know first it's good to be back
around
[Laughter]
dana you said something a week ago i
think it was about a week ago right
after the inflation reduction act was
signed
you said if you were advising the
president you don't know why he would go
back to i think he was in south carolina
he should have gone on the road and
promoted it
i think that was that that's what they
should have done and i think it would
have allowed for
a different kind of entry into the
political season i mean we're two months
away i think the president president
biden's been on a receiving end over the
last few months of some
pretty interesting verbal attacks and
other characterizations of his
presidency and he's going to give he's
going to give a little bit back i mean
we shouldn't be surprised by that uh i
think you know you think about
presidents in the past president obama
was called a socialist a terrorist he
was called someone wasn't born in the
united states even after he'd surveyed
four years and eight years in the
presidency so this is a little bit
politics now now this does go against
the brand because president biden when
he was running said he wanted to unite i
thought he gave him the great speeches
when he was when he uh his inaugural
address which really accentuated
amplified all of these points but here
here we are in this season and it's
probably going to get a little messier
we've had a few republicans say things
negative about president president trump
and one thing is for certain judge that
president biden has looked at
i can feel my friend's incredible energy
of love uh and unity coming towards me
uh one of the things that we we found uh
the polling data shows us is that the
only person who was more divisive on a
national level than president biden is
president former president trump so
which we shouldn't be surprised that the
parties are going to try to use a little
bit of this as they get going but we'll
see how it fairs he may be punished for
this because he wanted to be a unifier
or as i think was peter alexander in one
of the clips said he could very well
energize democrats as we know maybe
midterms are about energizing your baby
is this his deplorables moment judge it
clearly is but peter alexander just to
follow up on what harold said said this
is a guy who said he wanted to be a
unifier that's peter alexander saying
that look what joe biden did was he
started
the this rhetoric that was so insulting
he should remember 73 million or 74
million americans voted for donald trump
he should also recognize that in the
primaries in these primaries before the
midterms donald trump's tap on the
shoulder of a candidate was for many of
them the winning nod that they needed i
think it's sheer stupidity to do that
but worse than that this is hatred
fascism is something that americans hate
we connected with world war ii my father
fought in world war ii my grandfather as
well i mean we connect that with people
killing americans fighting for freedom
you don't do that because you know of
hatred and this kind of
rhetoric leads to violence that's the
way it is hate is hate hate leads to
violence and violence leads to
retaliation now the the left may have
decided they need to gin things up and
they want to see joe biden get a little
more excited but 56 percent of the
democrats don't want biden to run for
re-election so this is how the guy who
apparently lied when he said he wanted
to be the unifier and the adult in the
room this is how he's he's getting them
ginned up it's by hating the other side
that's not what we're talking about you
know what i'm tired to be honest with
you of what they said about obama we're
not talking about obama we're talking
today about what joe joe biden called at
least 75 million americans who voted and
a hell of a lot more who didn't the
other thing is as the head of the
democratic party he is giving basically
the go-ahead to everybody else in the
party to say similar things here is the
colorado secretary of state jenna
griswold she said that she claimed that
americans could lose the right to vote
within months
if the republicans win elections joey
yeah well you know i live in georgia the
home of jim crow 2.0
or as we like to call it the biggest
voter turnout ever in the state of
georgia so it depends on how you look at
it listen
if you're republicans you're probably i
doubt a lot of liberals and joe biden
supporters are watching this right now i
hope so i hope you're learning i hope
you tune in and learn but if not listen
don't get outraged get the tape don't
get offended be vindicated he is showing
you that his track record of saying
racist things and coherent things
divisive things is absolutely intact
don't let him realize how bad it is let
him continue to talk for the next
several months then make a bunch of
commercials and roll them out in october
and early november and win this primary
or win this midterm and win it strong
this is a this is a coherent plan that
they've put together this is their
strategy you know you back trump
candidates in the primaries which we saw
them do to try to get the trump
candidates on the ballot all right then
you do this create negative headlines by
slow rolling the january 6 committee
perhaps so mar-a-lago raid was a part of
this i don't know
that's phase two and now is the phase
where you take and you try to convince
the country that simply being
conservative is equivalent to every
horrible thing they've ever said about
president trump and you try to put us
all in one basket of deplorables
well i think we're also out of phase
where the operative question jimmy is
what won't biden do or say to get a few
more far left voters energized i don't
think anything is beneath him and let's
be clear like none of us really took him
seriously when he said he wanted to
unite the country most days he can't
unite enough words to form a complete
sentence if we're being honest but it's
disgusting because we've never seen an
attack on the voter okay like the
hillary attack was something she didn't
want to get out we all knew she felt
that way but she wasn't actually out at
a public event when that came out of her
mouth and for all the divisiveness for
trump he was attacking media he was
attacking his opponents he wasn't
attacking the people and i think what
this speaks to heading into the midterms
is a lack of a deliverable there's
nothing they can say to voters that
indicates their life is better off now
than it was two years ago which is why
instead you're not getting like uh you
know what they did on inflation or what
they did with the border cause it's
terrible so instead you're getting ultra
mega mega magga and i can't believe it's
not magga because they don't know where
to go i mean would you run on this
record what do you knock on the door and
say hey if you vote for us inflation
will be higher you know you like
fentanyl overdose deaths you're in
trouble you know you're in luck it's
terrible so it's it was the way for them
to get on offense and be offensive it is
very offensive and it's offensive to me
because i talk to these you know folks
on the radio every day i meet them at
comedy events they're the nicest people
in the world they don't care about race
they don't care about rights they don't
want to take away your rights they just
want to make a little money and drink a
lot of beer that's who they are and see
you at the concert hey girl they better
all right i'm sure reno is still reeling
from that performance over the weekend
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now